l'histoire du château de
chaumont-sur-loire remonte à l'an mil
tout d'abord forteresse de garde il se
transforme au fil de ses propriétaires
en un château d'agrément il héberge deux
grandes figures catherine de médicis
diane de poitiers sa rivale nostradamus
plus tard benjamin franklin puis la
famille princière de breuil aujourd'hui
le domaine se vouent sur 32 hectares à
la rencontre entre patrimoine paysage et
création artistique
chantal colleu dumond directrice du
domaine organise depuis quelques années
un programme culturel ambitions
il ya énormément de place pour le
paysage à chaumont ceux-là il ya le
grand paysage dans lequel nous nous
trouvons il ya le paysage qui a été
travaillée qui est derrière nous par du
chan le paysagiste appelé par la famille
de brouille au 19ème début 20e pour
sculpter le parc et puis il ya tous les
micros paysage sur lesquels on travaille
nous dans le domaine avec des artistes
avec des paysagistes tous les jardins
que nous avons sont de petits paysages
et donc beaucoup de créations en suspens
dans ce lieu
des oeuvres qu'installe les artistes
sont en dialogue avec le paysage et
elles doivent trouver leur juste place
je pense que ce qui fait la force la
poésie la beauté des oeuvres installées
par les artistes c'est qu' il n'y a pas
une accumulation gratuite mais la
recherche de la juste place qui donne
l'impression visiteurs que l'oeuvre est
là depuis toujours
oh
depuis 2012 le domaine s'agrandit avec
la création du parc de gwen on avait mis
ça dans un coin là dans
dix hectares dédiés là aussi à la
création paysagère et artistique
ce parc est destiné à accueillir des
jardins liées aux grandes civilisations
du jardin donc on a derrière nous un
premier jardin perret d'esprit chinois
et ce jardin à desjardins satellites qui
sont conçus par de grands paysagistes
d'aujourd'hui est donc on est à la fois
dans la création contemporaine et en
même temps en lien avec cette très
grande utilisation du jardin qui est le
jardin chinois et donc on continuera
avec des jardins japonais desjardins et
anglais au fait les grands titres
iations du jardin
un peu plus loin qu'il expérimenta les
plus ludiques c'est le festival
international des jardins pour sa 22e
édition c'est la thématique des
sensations biais des choisi scénographe
designer paysagiste plasticien nous
propose 25 micro jardins desjardins qui
se voit s'écoute se touchent se sentent
depuis 20 ans c'est plus de 500 jardins
éphémères qui voulait créer ici
on va continuer à être un lieu
d'expérimentation d'observation des
tendances dans le domaine du jardin et
du paysage avec cette volonté de plus en
plus affirmée d'internationalisation et
pour nous c'est très important de créer
des liens des ponts avec
c'est ce qui dans leur pays ont une
réflexion sur leurs paysages sur la
protection du paysage je pense que c'est
pour chaumont aussi une manière de
travailler sur la protection de
l'environnement et la beauté du paysage
à une échelle plus large
avec en 2013 30 mille enfants accueillis
dans un cadre pédagogique et quatre cent
mille visiteurs le domaine de chaumont
centre d'art et de nature offre un
regard multiples sur le croisement entre
art les paysages